hey there and welcome to Westeros weekly
the show that answers your biggest
questions about every episode of Game of
Thrones I'm Phillip Melina and back with
me this week hi I'm Erik Voss I missed
him a lot last week it was very very
hard to do this alone and I got a lot of
comments about what I'm like as a drunk
reminder by the way all of our Game of
Thrones coverage is available in our
Westeros weekly podcast feed so get our
season 8 content in audio form earlier
than you do in the video version you can
look without what's gross weekly feed on
iTunes wherever you get your podcast
also though remember to check out our
new MCU podcasts it's called inside
Marvel it has all of our adventures
content it insanely that podcast is like
number six and TV and film and we just
launched it's like wow
things we've ever had let's see this
Marvel thing must be popular with people
I hope it keeps going yes please so
anyway this week though we've got a
really just a ton of great questions
from you guys so we'll be answering
those and we're gonna do our weekly
Power Rankings we're also going to
update where we are and guess the throne
that pool
we finally have data back from that and
then we just normally start I think as
we should with the big question that's
on all our minds okay Wow off screen
Raven where's even the Raven that was
just the sound of the Raven and a man's
hand so always just come from this comes
from at stopped clock 17 on Twitter
asking what is Jamie's plan yeah yeah
okay so this was the question that
immediately I think like just from
watching was kind of wait a second cuz I
paused in this moment and I was like
okay he's going to realize he can't
leave the fight or something like that
he has to get back in there he's on the
side of the good guys now and then his
whole monologue there is no I'm not the
man that you think I am I am the bad guy
yeah it was it was a bit maddening you
know like we we saw him make the choice
so we were all kind of waiting for him
to make with Brienne and then I guess he
just had a change of heart you know
after they after he bedded her he have
to reclaim the Mountain Inn darienne's
terms you saw him kind of laying awake
in bed thinking like is this really who
I want and
there was a moment in season 4 when he
had sex with Cersei at the grave of
their child he says why not gods make me
love a woman you know it seems like he
feels cursed and he's kind of in this
self-defeating narrative in his own mind
where he has to cast himself as a
villain yeah you know what why would you
just reminded me is it's just the timing
of this what a worse like there's no one
has a worst story about your first times
results right she's like oh I finally
had had my first time having sex and it
made the man leave like the the safety
of the cities and to go to a certain
death go back to his girlfriend like
this is this is what sex is like yeah
it's especially tragic for Brienne
because yeah we know her history of
being like teased and right distrusting
men thinking being strung along thinking
that men are really interested in her
but it's actually some kind of cruel
joke and that's always been kind of her
story so it's back to the Wendel and
Christie's performance in that moment
where she I mean we just saw previously
that smile that she finally like lets
herself have but then this crushing like
it's almost like she let emotion in by
letting Jamie in and then we actually
saw like the most vulnerable we've ever
seen Bryan and it was heartbreaking
yeah but she would think about what
changed Jamie's mind he did hear that
news that Sansa received that you're on
Greyjoy is now in cahoots maybe develop
that name yes right so we're wondering
why now well it could be as simple as oh
right you're on still in the picture and
maybe he's gonna bed Cersei that was so
obviously what his goal was and maybe
it's just a little bit of jealousy but
also in the previous leads they made
sure to remind us that Jaime's fully
aware that sir she's pregnant
he knows he's the dad she says to him
that she's gonna say he's the father and
he has this incredulous look on his face
like really because we've never done
that before I don't know if you will he
might be savvy enough to realize you're
on is gonna claim it's his baby maybe
that would be good for sir she's plan so
he might actually not only it's that he
hates your on your on is going to
pretend to be the father of history
which in one way alone is enough to
motivate him but I think the real
question is is can we take him at face
value for what he's saying is motivating
him is he really going down there to
join Cersei and fight for her and defend
her her well there's there's two ways
this goes so let's make the case for why
he might join her see well he he does in
this kind of It's Not You It's Me speech
debris and by saying that Cersei is
hateful and so is he and maybe as I said
before this is just kind of his ownself
villainy narrative and he sees himself
as the villain he's done all kinds of
awful things and he's been reminded of
it during this return to Winterfell
he pushed bran stark out the window he
said he would have would have killed
everyone in Riverrun that was back in
season six right when he reunited with
Brienne outside those that place she is
his twin they have the same DNA their
paths have always been linked and maybe
he feels that no amount of good deeds
can ever change that
and maybe he sees it as his destiny and
maybe you know you were bringing up this
idea of you're on if you're on was
specifically the trigger what if he
feels that urine poses a threat to
Cersei that by in neurons eyes
impregnating her he no longer needs the
Queen and so by going down south to
King's Landing he's going to protect
Cersei against Iran because he sees this
kind of Pirate King as someone who just
wants an heir and once that's out of the
picture he has no reason to have Cersei
right well and also you're on Greyjoy
based on on his character in the books
but also we've seen is a reckless
warrior so he's not gonna care about
surgery or any of them really surviving
this the Greyjoy's to have our as a as a
people are like pretty suicidal yeah we
do not so we yeah yeah we die but and
then we have reborn but still so there
is that that option and one reason why
well I'm gonna come back to actually a
reason why I think that is I think we
gotta take my face value but we have to
acknowledge enough people are tweeting
us about this that they think no it
can't be right he's on his way to kill
Cersei yes and you know we're just
getting a big ol misdirect right now so
if we consider this option and take it
seriously we got to remember that Brian
labeled him
good man she is potentially the same
voice of not reason about the the like
almost like it takes someone noble and
good to be able to label someone else
that way the same way that a knight can
Knight make another night she by doing
that is doing what branded for Theon hmm
right by saying I want you to know that
as a good person or for a brand actually
I was just an all-knowing person you are
definitively good so if we are to take
her words as more valuable than his then
it could be he is a good man and that
opens up the option of maybe he doesn't
even realize why he's going down there
and last second he can change his mind
yeah and and in the ultimate moment you
know have the moment he had with the Mad
King where it was if it's the people or
this person maybe just last moment he
will still turn out to be a good man but
then also there's um the all these
things that that he did that he said he
did wrong the show spent years making
him atone for them mm-hmm so for him to
still suffer them and go back to them I
mean that's kind of like a bit of
undoing yeah a lot of what is it would
be odd for Jaime just to go back to the
villain that he was in season one and
season two he needs to have changed even
if he goes back to you know cyclically
return to some of this story beats that
he was at the beginning with the the Mad
King may be returned to the Mad Queen we
need to show how he changed and by
killing his sister not only would that
bring him full circle with this whole
idea of defending the realm by killing
this crazy monarch it brings them full
circle with this idea of the Fallen
choir theory from the books which is not
really in the show but this whole idea
of the woods which that Cersei met when
she was a young girl kind of brought up
this idea of you will die by the Valen
quarter which is high Valyrian word for
a younger brother
some people were interpreted that to be
Tyrion who has made his fair share of
threats my brother
smaller brother but as her twin Jaime
was born a couple minutes after her so
he could be the one to deliver that
death stroke also I just want to put out
there bran said to him the the reason I
didn't want to throw you under the bus
and in sentence you to death is because
you have a greater role to play in the
worst to come and to be honest in the
Battle of Winterfell
what really
his cool moment with Brienne where they
both do shadowboxing kind of you know
right they they they got backed up
against the wall and started killing a
bunch of whites that would eventually
die when re-establishing and yet they
essentially they survived
what is this greater role if not to kill
sir right and then finally I'll say that
the ultimate completion was art so bran
actually forgave him essentially for for
pushing him out the window he said it
was essential for everything that that's
happened so that means like the worst of
the things that we know that Jamie's
done or arguably maybe the worst is
something that has already been like
forgiven so then if we are actually
still continuing his arc and this is a
misdirect
then the finality of that arc would get
to the root of it all which is Cersei
all those things that he did for love he
did for Cersei so killing Cersei would
ultimately finally make him fully uh
find it you know immense and potentially
be labeled as a good man it might be the
last act he ever does but you know it
might be the deciding factor in his good
place number score right it'll be
interesting to see if he actually
delivers the blow though like I could
see him getting right up to the point
where he's got the sword in his hand
he's ready to strike down but he just
can't bring himself to do it but that
moment of weakness isn't a way a
redemptive moment for Jaime Lannister at
the end of the series so maybe he
doesn't survive his like mission to go
kill Cersei but he at least gets up to
the the plate for it I mean entering
this conversation I felt more sure than
I do now
all right I think we are really supposed
to be torn about him but I want to call
out something that I think this episode
was about whether or not it was about
this thematically overall there
certainly was this recurring personal
character motif of that's not me right
we know Ari says that where she is I'm
not the lady she's obviously she's
referencing the first time she said that
to Ned Stark but also that moment with
my mariya where you know that's not you
it's acknowledgment that's who you want
me to be but that isn't Who I am
Jaime is having that moment that's who
you want me to be that's not who I am
Gendry saying you know I'm not a lord
I'll even bron right where we all want
to be remembering that bran was these
guys is best friend
number of times he has to love them deep
down he's like no that's not me I'm
wearing it for the money I've said it
since the beginning and I think that's
what that bolt next to Jamie's head is
saying is no you like the fandom are
confused about who these characters
really are and who we really are and we
got one moment of happiness
we all had sex every character on Game
of Thrones finally had the or gee they
were building to all these years the red
orgy and then they all realize that's
the life I wish I could have but it's
probably not the life I will write yeah
this post battle feast kind of felt like
the epilogue that was maybe in people's
fan fictions but every character pivoted
away from that happy ending into the
ending that they really have been right
directly toward the most telling moment
of that's not me is in that that moment
there with with Daenerys trying to like
will the epilogue being joyful right
right oh I'm gonna label Gendry as the
Lord of storms end people are gonna talk
to me because of it I mean still
strategic but you know there's the
cheers moment it all feels like isn't
this working and then we get that shot
where she realizes no it's not working
right yeah that's kind of I think maybe
telling for everyone it's not working
she was awkwardly sips her to-go cup of
coffee
well there see mistake they should never
be allowed to be forgiven for that this
show should be canceled yeah before the
final I think they should end it in yes
yeah seems like a just punishment yeah
well real real quick no you you stay
right there Raven I want to point out by
the way we've got images at the
beginning this is the episode where we
are going to announce the winner of our
Stardust like contest whatever the word
I'm supposed to use I feel like legally
I'm suppose to use a specific word the
star does have the habit a Sheree the
person who and and a friend who are
going to get flown out to hang out with
us and watch special VIP screening of
Game of Thrones the finale episode and
hang out with us while we do an episode
of Westeros weekly that person is going
to be announced later this episode
which I'm really excited to share with
you guys yes me too yeah all right there
you go Raven yeah oh we just hovered
there like a drone is impressive also I
want to see the Raven again by the way
I'm the Raven looking like a man's hand
is creeping me out like a furry mammal
his normal at happy Lygia happily Hsieh
wants to know what is varus's plan
that's a real interesting question right
was because everyone's partying and
Varys clearly is doing the same thing
that danny is doing where he's doing the
math of everyone in the room and he's
reading everyone's facial expression
it's what I do when I go to parties yeah
I don't say a word and I shave my head
completely bald and I just wear weird
tunic possibly hiding a mermaid tail and
just stare around and see where the
where the shadow on the cave wall lies
well Barry says told us multiple times
that he serves a realm and he just wants
a leader that's best for all of its
people his allegiances have changed so
many times over the course but it's all
coming from this same motivation of he
wants what's best for everyone for the
kids of the realm for the people don't
go starving remember in season 5 episode
1 he said he wanted a ruler stronger
than Tommen but gentler than Stannis a
monarch who can intimidate the High
Lords and inspire the people a ruler
loved by millions with a powerful army
and the right family name George
Clooney's teeth a little bit of Monica a
little bit and the Sun and this episode
he said that John is a man which makes
him more appealing to the Lords of
Westeros who support we're going to need
and you got imagine as a eunuch Varys
must feel like a sting of guilt about
that for saying that someone needs the
right genitalia to be the ruler of
Westeros but I think he's just looking
at this pragmatically like he said we
want to win over as many rulers as we
need we're not in the military strength
position that we were a couple seasons
back now we really need to play the
political game a lot more yeah I mean
he's the one that is still absolutely
playing the game of Thrones yes yeah
Varys is back to what like Varys was in
seasons two and three like he's been
kind of wandering since he left Westeros
and now he's back to the conspire that
he was at the beginning and isn't that
another example of all the characters
that we've come to love who they became
and then they're reminding us with their
choices were like
please don't do that but actually there
like this is who I always was yes you're
the one that thought better of me
absolutely now Tyrion asks various what
will happen to Daenerys and Varys says
I've spoken as honestly as I can and
then he tells Tyrion each of us has a
choice to make I pray we choose wisely
it actually echoes that moment remember
in the godswood when brand told John
it's your choice who water me or let me
die but this whole idea of like it's
leaving the choice up to someone else
but really clearly there's an obvious
choice to make like this illusion of
choice like the cell sword and the
riddle that he told Tyrion back in
season 3 season 2 when he said you know
it's it's all an illusion powers an
illusion like it's just the choice lies
with the self sword in the middle based
off where he believes power resides he's
asking Tyrion to pick between Daenerys
and John right that's the choice that
he's asking
I think Varys has already made up his
mind to sell it Daenerys for John right
I mean some people are wondering did he
already yes Oh have there already been I
mean how did your on know where they
were headed to Dragonstone right and
yeah yeah it's like are there little
birds that are carrying my real opinion
is that you know Qyburn has his own
little birds and he's he's got spies out
in the field as well but you know people
have a decent argument that there's a
decent chance that this guy's playing
the game so well that he's trying to
make it seem like he's figuring this out
with Tyrion but of course he's already
made his moves and made up his mind yeah
to spy networks of children two teams of
Newsies if you will were out spying each
other and like a kids version of the
Americans
that's where Game of Thrones is headed
that's one of those spin-off series that
were most excited about marriage we're
Americans here to kill so here's the
theory that we're thinking about right
now that maybe Varys was told I'm
Melisandre last season well we know that
she told him that when they were when
they they would both die in this strange
land and maybe her half of that was
right like Varys has a history with the
old Lord of Light he was cut by a wizard
who's still in a box somewhere and that
wizard threw his parts into the brazier
and he heard a voice and he believes
that he has
kind of historical connection with the
red God and maybe that's part of his
destiny now there was also that red
priestess in Essos can vara who knew all
about varus has passed somehow even
though there's never told her they had
never met and that creeped him out so
maybe various will be the answer to
Davos this question from earlier this
episode about what the Lord of lights
true plans or what he wants now that the
night king is dead
does varus have a role to play and bring
it about the Lord of lights true agenda
then maybe the Lord of Light hasn't
abandoned them and that he has like a
specific person he wants on the Iron
Throne and it's Varys his role to
Shepherd that person to the throne yeah
right I mean it would it would be you
know for trusting our show my show
runners here it would be that the thread
of the Lord of the light of Lord light
is not done right and it also might mean
that if Varys is still manipulating
things for a lord of light purpose
especially the person is questioning the
most often seems the most linked just in
like religious texts I it would also
mean that Jon Snow might still be
playing a role yes hopefully because
there's just been so much for shadowing
with him in Daenerys that they must have
some kind of role to play in this
endgame otherwise all that foreshadowing
would just feel for naught and they'll
feel kind of empty if if that's the way
the show just decides to forget it but
even if the Lord of Light its presence
isn't literal on the show Varys is
perception that the Lord of Light it's
kind of this coming back again to this
whole idea of the self sword between the
king the priest and the rich man its
power resides where Varys believes it
resides and if he believes himself as a
tool of the Lord of Light then that
enough is enough of a motivation for him
to make the next move but before we
continue we want to give quick thanks to
some sponsors who helped us make this
video sorry with hellofresh hellofresh
is a meal kit delivery service at shops
plans and delivers step-by-step recipes
and pre measured ingredients so that you
can just cook and eat and enjoy I've
done it it's it's wonderful it's
delicious yes they have really really
delicious and simple recipes they do all
the meal planning and shopping and
prepping so you can just focus on being
a healthier you there are three plans to
choose from the classic the veggie in
the family with the option to switch it
if you change your mind you can spend
less time meal planning a grocery
shopping
that you're gonna spend more time doing
what you love like scouring Game of
Thrones episodes for any shot the bear
wolves they're out there somewhere right
are there ghosts howl of you can hear me
hello fresh has simplified my dinner
time I've really loved all the food the
pulled pork Fiesta Bowl
there was a cherry balsamic chicken I
really liked and it's become hands-down
my favorite meal kit delivery service
for $80 off your first month oppelo
fresh go to hellofresh comm slash rock
stars 80 and enter promo code rock stars
80 it's like receiving eight meals for
free go to hellofresh comm slash rock
stars 80 and enter promo code rock stars
84 $80 off your first month of
hellofresh
meal delivery kits a true story eric
invited me to one of those dinners and
did not tell us it was hella fresh he
said he prepared it all by himself and
did all the shopping alone i'm finding
out the truth right here but we're also
excited to I think one of our other
newest sponsors actually says Mack
Weldon they make really smartly design
men's clothing and their user experience
is probably one of the easiest and most
convenient out there they made their
name with men's underwear and they've
got really cool underwear actually I
genuinely feel this way you can tell
right now that I'm like giddy about it
because they have silver sewn into the
underwear so it's antimicrobial so you
can just like tune into that puppy but
they're anti odor so actually like you
know it feels like we're in silver
obviously underwear that it's doing what
it should be doing yeah I'm all about
fancy tech underwear that's like one of
my hobbies so they've actually don't
expand it beyond underwear and they have
all kinds of men's clothing like
sweatshirts and hats and swim trunks all
kinds of stuff I just ordered some of
their t-shirts because I like the colors
and they had 16 to pick from the website
was easy to use the whole process was
super convenient I also got some of the
silver one to wear underwear of course
because I have to test its limits and
I'm very excited to I'm just like in a
lab coat in the underwear and I was like
it for science book for 20% off your
first order head to Mac Walden comm and
enter promo code Westeros at checkout
again that's promo code Westeros Mac
Walden comm 20% off your first order
thank you so much that fara sponsor and
stuff said we literally could not do the
show without these guys but let's talk
about people who we also apparently can
do the game with our own show without
now their watch has ended yes the
characters that we remember in memoriam
though the ones who we lost this episode
starting with Ragle ho boy man this is
why we're both wearing black yeah yeah
yeah
so if 150 pounds of jon snow was too
much for him to carry maybe he shouldn't
have been flying off to war oh come on
don't just say he's a mythological beast
that was the equivalent of nukes in this
world and I'm happy that were decorated
yes oh boy it's it's it was God even
it's still it's just yeah but it was sad
to see Daenerys lose yet another child
she's losing so much this episode of
really as a descent into madness and
seeing this one was was even harder for
me than seeing Vaziri on I mean does it
feel like Danny is somewhat to blame for
her I mean she she if I'll say if drogon
had gone down then she absolutely would
have been to blame because she is
absolutely letting her rage well Sansa
did say maybe we should give the troops
some time to recuperate and recover and
we saw how ragel had holes in his wings
I don't know how long he's dragging but
it would have been nice to see him
adjust his flying a bit yeah he was
pretty wobbly
the last thing I said before that which
was a super shocking moment was he looks
like he's getting better how long you
were man well maybe he's now he has
gills through those neck coals and he's
swimming around the water he became a
fish that's unnecessary
or as like D&D said after the episode
nice on D like yeah we've all the
characters been saying it wrong to hold
on oh come on miss on day means more to
Daenerys because as she told John and
Thomas last episode she was not our
queen because she's a daughter some King
we never met she's the queen we chose
she's the one who broke their chains she
freed her from a stupor so they had this
whole like that's why she she fights for
that's why she serves her and we got a
hint of that with her final words she
said the word jerk Horace which is high
Valyrian it's the term that Daenerys
says to the dragon to say light it up
which also
maybe could have some other meaning that
we'll talk about but it's not a call
back it's a call back to the moment that
Daenerys said your car stood to roast
crassness in a stupor this is a slave
trader that tried to take drug on it was
this big fiery moment that freed all of
them the unsullied including miss Andre
yeah so it kind of brings her back to
that moment of like that freedom it was
so it was a word that freed her and now
it's the word that frees her from this
life yeah so speaking of what what miss
Andre was doing I think we have a
question oh I swear if this bird doesn't
start flying soon this thing started
with a contraption with a zip line at
the beginning of this and it now
literally frisbee it in that question
this bird all right well this bird
brought a question from at Brizzy b-24
wondering did Miss Sunday saying
dracarys foreshadowed an e burning down
King's Landing
so I mean obviously this is a bigger
question so we should take a moment here
because it certainly is trying to do
that right she drew cars is the
translation to basically burn it all
down right which is obviously very
reminiscent to another Targaryen having
burned them all in his head and and him
screaming that so yeah I mean it's
definitely doing that especially it's
connecting to Danny's vision that we saw
in the house of the undying of the
burned-out throne room when we a lot of
people were saying it was covered in
snow
maybe but also that just could be ash
right right if it's if it's burning down
the whole time you have the roof was
caved in and right yeah the Iron Throne
looked like it was gone or decimated so
yeah yes so it would finally pay that
off and that's you know a lot of the
prophecies are on in Game of Thrones I'm
talking about in the books don't
necessarily have counterparts in the
show like the ballot card prophecy but
this one's one we straight-up saw this
earlier in the series I feel like that
means that we're potentially gonna see
that again so that also would set us up
for a repeat of the Mad King up against
maybe Jaime Lannister having the ability
to take down the mad Queen if that is
where Danny was headed and certainly
like the fall of Daenerys Targaryen
mental health this episode right she's
lost two of her closest advisors because
they don't won't like Jorah is is gone
yeah and then also she has advisors
betraying her honestly yeah I then she
also lost her her son you know show in
Mehsana being one of the trust advisors
but but then Varys is his support is
gone she's lost the the support of the
people of the north that she she kind of
never had but she thought she might for
a second I
she's definitely headed toward what is
is I was gonna say madam but there's a
word for it it's madness and she's
headed toward that and then she says
that her destiny is to rid the world of
tyrants but no matter the cost so yes we
are absolutely headed toward the at
least what's being poor shattered is
that Daenerys Targaryen is gonna burn
down all of King's Landing but the
question is do we have actually two mad
Queens right now yeah both of whom are
showing they're willing to burn things
in order to get what they want it was
interesting that both Daenerys and
Cersei are wearing red this episode you
know it's almost like these battle-ready
mad Queens who might be willing to not
be afraid to bleed into their clothes to
get what they did never look more like
yeah the the two of them are echoing
each other in a lot of ways I'm looking
forward to you know breaking this
further down in the breakdown but yeah
it's almost like a competition of which
Queens willing to be madder and they're
both doing specific things to provoke
each other it's they aren't plain smart
um chess right now they're they're both
like trying to knock pieces off the
board which we saw Daenerys do when she
toppled the lion which she hasn't
toppled the line yet it was just like
angry like I don't want this line to be
what and breaking the wheel I mean it
sounded cool at one point but the wheel
is progress rotate like the wheel is
actually there for a reason
breaking the wheel is what you do when
you know you're you're mad at in a game
of Monopoly right like that's how you
win or the game of life you just take
that stupid wheel which will never spend
correctly and you just snap it and then
we all have to go to our rooms and my
mom takes the board games away V and I'm
there too yes
what the it's it's totally interesting
to see both these characters the episode
titles the last of the starts but
they're both like the last of their
lines and in their own respective houses
Daenerys feels like the last of the
Targaryen because she feels isolated
from the only other targeting she knows
which is John Cersei feels like the last
Lannister because jaylen has an interior
yeah
so as the last of their lines they feel
desperate they feel ready to lash out
because they don't really have a future
in their minds they're just operating
from pure base it raw emotion in in this
drive to power just to prove that they
want to wince that the other side
doesn't win yeah zero-sum game
one of the most believable things I
think okay so here's here's the thing I
feel like I actually haven't been
looking to see how people are feeling
about this episode I have a feeling
they're gonna be torn or they are torn
already because there's a lot of these
turns for these characters and I said
why I thought that was I think they're
all having their that's not me moment
but I gotta say this episode was really
long and I think they devoted as much
time as they could essentially a movies
worth amount of time to drive Dany mad
to really actually justify her being
there and I kind of wanna what whether
or not they're like totally nailing it I
want to applaud the effort of we need to
mess this person's mind up in as many
different ways as possible to get her to
just where she's been already in this
whole time but I gotta say I mean I
don't think anyone at the end was
watching and thinking to themselves I
don't know she's probably all right I
think we all bought it but I like yeah
she's gonna make some real bad noises
real soon
yeah and I mean you buy it you see it on
her face it's all yeah you saw it at the
beginning the episode at the feast when
she's looking around from table to table
I'm the only one who doesn't have a
family to grieve with and to celebrate
with this sucks
and Varys sees that in her eyes too he's
the first one to notice who there's
something not right here
I might have backed the wrong so will it
burn I think yes right it's destined to
burn down who sets the fire I think
that's kind of the one of the last fun
mysteries was it always burning since
the world's been turning yeah we didn't
start it for sure yeah
oh oh look at this little fella what are
you doing who was the person throwing it
if not you would that person go
interested okay well at I Kaito wants to
know will the destiny of the direwolves
reflect on their remaining owners which
is something we've we've actually
theorized before multiple times that the
direwolves are connected like
metaphysically to their owners yeah
definitely there's a stronger connection
between the stark children and their
direwolves in the books the show out of
maybe this stays for how much CGI budget
or how difficult it is to look in
production with dogs it's not easy it
requires a lot of like things yeah yeah
in the books real quick though it is
they're essentially if you're a stark
you potentially can warg into into any
animal guess and there is more that warg
style connection with every star child
and and their dire what they can kind of
feel each other so if the show decides
in these last two episodes they do
actually want to follow in this
connection how was Santa's dire wolf
lady killed she was put down by Ned in
episode two of the series at the demand
of Cersei could this foreshadow Sansa
being held captive or and in
foreshadowed Sansa as like a scapegoat
being held captive by the Lannisters so
that we saw a connection there right but
also the lady version of Sansa is gone
right that character did die and died
away and she became as the princess of
her but she's become a lady in the child
sure but the conceptual like the way
they described being a lady and just
like right the dainty one who likes to
do embroidery but and then there's Robin
Grayland which is one of the more
painful ones both are amazing in battle
they talk about how they actually worked
seamlessly energy in the books they talk
about how it's almost like they have
this mental connection where you know
they they weave and Bob together like a
great basketball player somebody they
that's very bad boxers if they're
working together yeah but I mean they
literally switch heads at death yeah
they have equal the interchangeable
deaths in the same way they died yeah
Rickon and shaggy-dog both died
by the you know shaggy dog died by the
umbers and he was like brought in and
then that foreshadowed how Rickon would
die when Ramsay Bolton fired arrows
because you know unfortunately Rickon
didn't know the serpentine movement but
yeah but also these are the houses like
turning against the north you know and
you know surprising us I guess with her
I mean the Bolton's at one point were
supposedly on the same side yeah so and
then connecting back to characters of
stole I bran still lie but summer died
forward bran along with Hodor north of
the wall or the great weirwood tree in a
way summer died when brand died and then
became the three-eyed Raven so summer
representing like the boy Brandon Stark
is now both are gone and now it's been
replaced by this like vacant psychic
tree boy yeah and so we saw in in this
episode that very direct callback to
Arya and I mean I'm areas relations oh
yeah
where Arya says that's not me and that's
a you know basically what she says with
my merit that's not you but they're also
these these figures that are these
female like beasts homos that are that
are so capable but they're out there
running in the wild alone doing their
their own thing and not actually there's
no it's not about allegiance and I mean
like just for a second aside from from
from the direwolf saying Arya doing her
own thing and not really caring about
what she's supposed to do is also what's
going on with Gendry but also feels like
a maybe a connection to what happened
who to start this whole thing with
Robert Baratheon another Baratheon being
rejected by another stark Leon sir okay
didn't didn't love him I don't know the
Aria doesn't love kendry I think she did
yeah
he doesn't love another but it's just
yeah yeah but it but just that again
like Brody is Gendry gonna start a new a
new war and then of course there's John
and ghost like when John sends ghost off
with tormund it kind of breaks our
hearts he's like a direwolf is no place
in the south and it's very similar to
what's not to said to tyrion about John
and King's Landing the men and my family
don't do well in the capital it's things
that belong in the north don't and
should not go to King's Landing and John
is saying that ghosts will be happier
north of wolterman says so do you know
so it's it's kind of like there's a
connection between John and ghost here
goes
wounded after the battle but like he it
just it feels wrong that they're being
separated and going in opposite
directions which so if all this stay is
true maybe that's foreshadowing John is
not gonna end up on the Iron Throne
right or the Y and Iron Throne
yeah like John's place does feel north
of the wall he felt truths while he was
with Ygritte and torment imagining him I
mean I know it's not as far south but
imagine him in Dorne right it's just so
out of place like he's just like it's
like putting him in Miami Beach yeah
look at this weird awkward tan yeah yeah
he's like the guy in the hotel elevator
it's like okay yeah just go back up
attest Cincinnati it's like when we saw
a kid Harrington shave his beard so many
after this war John will end up north of
the wall if he does survive maybe could
reform the Nights Watch remember he did
quote the vows of the Nights Watch and
it's funeral speech maybe that could be
implying his destiny but yeah I'm not
feeling too good about his survival if
this is what torment is saying I'm like
there was some prophetic to say you
bring up the funeral speech I think I
got tweeted some people asking me why
was his voice so different why while he
was delivering using his outside voice
yeah but he's used it before but it
didn't quite sound regal and I feel like
that was one thing that we were actually
supposed to be taking away from that is
this guy sounds like a king he kind of
sounds like Martin Luther King jr.
specifically but also he sounds like a
king and that's happening in front of
Daenerys Daenerys is not the one that's
shouting out there to everyone the
funeral speech unless she was like an
earlier act or something yeah but it's
him and I think that's just trying to to
add to the whole stress to her yeah damn
this guy is good and that's also what
Tyrion is responding to a barrister
responded to him yeah absolutely
oh okay from at Dorothy met 24 did Santa
tell Tyrion about Jon's parents because
she knew he'd tell other people yes yes
so much so gasps who's like oh don't
tell anyone else this yeah Jeff's
getting fired he kept that secret for
his entire life basically for Jon's
entire life
Sansa kept it for 12 minutes yes there's
no way that that was an accident
she is the student of Littlefinger she
knows that
it's a ripple effect she knows a couple
of chest moves ahead
she was already established she does not
support Daenerys mhm it this gives her
the way to stay aside and let chaos
happen and then I don't want to say that
she wants to climb the ladder like a
little finger did but it led John to
climb the ladder in a very clean way
that she can stay at up she doesn't put
the north at risk i ideally she doesn't
at least absolutely she was doing that
on purpose but also I mean actually
apply just a real bad secret keeper yeah
I mean she probably isn't one of
spreading the word about Arya cuz you
know they had a sisterly moment about
like hey me and gain free and then so
everyone knows a bunch of guys are going
by kendry be like nice okay at nerd soda
281 snow will your on wonder how tear in
our dnews Circe was pregnant that's a
great question so there's this moment
this episode where Cersei reveals to
Euron that she's pregnant and then
Tyrion who has not been in King's
Landing and since Circe's started having
sex with Iran he he signals in front of
your on that he already knows that
Cersei has a baby and Euron must be
wondering well wait I thought I gave her
the baby he sees thinking about timeline
it's basically like wait nine months
he's doing math in his head
and he's you know he was really excited
about being the one to put the prints
inside Cersei so he might be upset that
Cersei lied to him was this something
that Tyrion knew would cause some
disturbance in the ranks among Circe's
forces a way to this is might be why he
stepped away from Qyburn he's like I'm
gonna dress Cersei directly because I'm
gonna drop a bomb on them right now
hopefully cause some disagreement
between them yeah or he's dumb right and
doesn't know cuz you're on has not been
portrayed as brilliant right maybe maybe
a tactician of sorts definitely like a
crazy warrior but honestly I mean you
think he's like super aware of how this
all works he probably thinks that like
you know it would whenever she she has a
baby honestly i if sir she's really
slick about it she's going to have him
not around when she actually has the
baby and she's gonna lie about the exact
birth date
I should be like I'd like to go off to
Casterly Rock or something I would
to go have the baby you go find me the
greatest gift you can give your news new
son and then she's gonna like make it
off by a month or something and then I
don't know the Euron knows what a
newborn baby looks like oh they're
covered in jelly whatever he have to do
I don't know that he's that savvy and
worst case he probably would just think
they have spies too right the OBGYN has
a big mouth I think he's uh I think he's
definitely savvy enough he's become this
Pirate King by being by thinking a
couple steps ahead I just don't know if
in the heat of that moment he's actually
thinking the way that like pieces of
things fly over our heads all the time
yeah but but that's that if he it'd be
good if he did realize cuz that's some
good juicy drama yeah we want drama yeah
who do we got next okay all right ooh at
Lissy fawn uh okay so what did Danny
whisper to draw us so this is at the
very beginning of the episode some
people thought that she was just giving
him a very long kiss on his dead ear
she's whispering in there the show
actually made a point to not tell us
what she whispers the closed captions
even just say whispering and the they've
been a couple interviews about this now
it actually turns out the lines were not
scripted this was something that just
was between Emilia Clarke and what's the
name again Ian England yeah they had
just this moment of you know this is the
end of our relationship as actors
together too she expressed that she was
bawling at his death scene because she
knew it meant that she's not gonna get
to be with the guy who's been by her
side since the beginning of the series
literally like I mean we know me that
Clarke had some serious health troubles
throughout the show so she's saying this
is like one of her best friends but I in
England won't say what it is that she
said in his ear but he also said that it
was appropriate for the two of us as
actors and as people it was appropriate
for the character and it was appropriate
for the moment so it wasn't like penis
or something it was some stupid joke
which a lot of people like a bit it was
a joke it's like not yeah it kind of
evokes that moment at the end of Lost in
Translation where Bill Murray says
something to Scarlett Johansson it's
like a secret and you're never meant to
know it it's probably like the actor
said something like I'm too old for you
you're basically a teenager and I'm like
50
but also there is that moment and the
office like Michael Scott's final
episode we're like both him and and they
take off their microphones and then they
say something to each other we don't
know what it was we find out years later
that it's basically Pam said something
to seek Grail like oh you you meant so
much to me I'm gonna miss you so much on
the show it just kind of sound like you
can hear or say miss you somewhere in
there like you're the S sound which can
only mean miss you I am missing you at
all yeah all right so let's get into
some more video questions we get those
sent in via Stardust it's a social media
app where you just do if you're a film
and TV lover you can post your reactions
on there in video or text but we use
them as nice video Q&A s but remember we
also are hosting a contest through
Stardust of the people that tag at new
rockstars and submit a question and they
I follow a game of Thrones on Stardust
they are submitted to win the chance or
to win the flight to join us wherever we
have our Westeros weekly live episode in
our VIP viewing of the finale and all
you have to do to enter is submit these
questions basically and follow us we're
gonna announce a winner shortly but also
we still got another winner to pick and
one ounce of that one next week so make
sure you keep submitting those questions
through signatories let's go ahead and
take a look and listen yo yo yo Westeros
weekly with some new rock stars you the
best hey so my question is with all the
time that brands been spending in the
godswood at Winterfell do you think he's
gonna morph into the weirwood tree kind
of like the old three-eyed Raven I mean
it makes sense he's always sitting there
doing nothing not blinking might as well
be in a tree right yeah we might as well
be a tree I've never seen a tree blink
they probably do behind my back yeah
that would be an interesting place for
brand to go because I don't know what
other role he can play he's not going
with them I feel like he's given all the
information he can possibly give there
was an interesting line where you say I
live in the past which some people are
saying is everything we're seeing in
Game of Thrones in the past a vision of
like an older version of brand
experiencing this this past vision that
he's now like telling to someone else
so or does it mean that bran is living
in the past and he's like affecting
past events currently as we speak or has
already done it based off this version
of time travel that we've seen on the
show yeah but I don't see literally
transforming into tree no I think
growing old maybe and not see passing
and but also you know who knows in a
thousand years or so yeah I mean sure
over time you know a human after a
thousand years looks a lot like a tree
mm-hmm yeah so I've heard yeah another
question here hey so what is Sam going
to do now Gilly are they just going to
stay at Winterfell B say I'm going to be
new maester there that's a good question
yeah is what's gonna happen with Sam and
Gilly did they just get written up the
show is he is the he's to have a greater
role is he the one that's actually
recording the events of Game of Thrones
and that's what we're hearing but also I
think we should actually take a moment
to expand this blow this question out a
little bit because there were a lot of
characters that we said theoretically
said goodbye to this episode right
tormund says that Winterfell is far to
south for him
and so obviously King's Landing be way
too far south for him Gendry might be on
his way to storms end now and he'd you
know figuring out how to how to be Lord
he could show up to help Arya right
could suddenly happen and Brienne is
probably you know right now she's she's
in this interesting place where she's
sworn to stay and protect Sansa and then
prevent Jaime's headed south
so that theoretically is a character we
might not see any more as the show head
south what do you think could you who's
who's gonna show up again basically at
all
I think injuries gonna show up again I
think it's interesting and I'll bring
this up more in my breakdown but the
fact that Gentry was legitimized this
episode is a really big deal because
depending on how you'd look at the the
power lineage the succession of monarchs
Daenerys and John's claim to the throne
is Pru is presuming pre robert baratheon
usurping rules that they're saying that
that was illegitimate
but really it's Circe's holding of the
iron throne is through her connection to
the Baratheon in the fact that Gendry is
now legitimized Baratheon he is a true
heir successor to Robert Baratheon and
if Cersei and Daenerys and John all
cancel
they're out in the coming events injury
now is the direct claim to the Iron
Throne so I think Gendry is now being
set up to play a bigger role obviously
Brienne story isn't done it needs to not
be done right I think we've got a really
interesting thing she's she's never
broken an oath right but what does that
mean if right now also you have the
other stark girl that she's supposed to
protect is headed south - she could kind
of like be like oh I'm not really
breaking my oath I'm headed there for
Ferrari or something but I do you think
it's gonna be that that she would leave
Sansa like I mean obviously you know
there's not as much a threat right now
right but to go to King's Landing is is
kind of against the character that at
least she was you know maybe a month ago
we'll see there's a lot of tin foil out
there that the knight King might not be
dead or the knight King might come back
we haven't seen the last of the White
Walkers I don't really buy most of it
but there was just some interesting
Telegraph in when torments like I'm
going back to castle like why tell us
where he's going at all you know why not
a storyteller as a screenwriter of this
episode just leave him hanging out at
Winterfell the fact that it's going back
to Castle black there was some of this
like we you'll see kind of language like
you maybe another threat from the north
that could be facing Winterfell I'll say
that the show did induce what I what I
would call cinematic goodbyes where it's
kind of give someone a hero shot really
like give them play some of a theme
maybe that is appropriate to them and
give them just like the kind of goodbye
honestly that ghost deserved yes ghost
didn't even get their proper goodbye
either yeah
on my Twitter you can see what a proper
goodbye to a wolf looks like but I think
that that may be pretty telling too that
we might see these characters again
especially Sam and Gilly right that
doesn't feel over either
so what I'll say when I said boo earlier
about the night king coming back I don't
want them to bring my King back but I'd
be pretty into something like there's a
new night king now or something or some
other version of a threat that shows
that that is going to be a continuing
battle maybe even beyond the events of
this show right maybe one of the
spin-off series of the three that george
RR martin said right now we're going
forward yeah yeah so i mean they could
all come back but if they don't it's a
little bit of a bummer but we have one
more starters question that we want to
look
give it a play yes open to rock stars
we've got are you headed down we've got
the Hound headed down what do you think
they're doing I love that we have this
Arya Hound reunion I think that's great
but how on Stacy's got some unfinished
business I'm definitely feeling it
Clegane bull although I wouldn't mind
seeing grey worm take the mountain down
and then also with Arya I think we all
kind of are guessing that she's about to
take downstairs II would love to see the
SS and do that but do we actually think
Arya is gonna take her down or she might
have her sights on someone else who
knows that's a really good question
smashing ivory I think that well first
of all yeah we're headed toward clicking
bull right everything that he was the
unfinished business is not chickens or
something he ate the sweet sweet kings
and enjoyment but the the so yes that
but the question about is Arya you know
is that what her unfinished business is
it Cersei Lannister is still on her list
is she cocky right now and she's like I
took down the night king I can take down
the you know blonde queen but I got a
feel like storytelling wise doesn't also
feel like it can't be are you now yeah
she's already played her role she's a
it's gonna be a crucial role but to kill
both the villains from one character it
seems kind of overkill
I'm I'd be interested to see if she
takes on Qyburn like if Qyburn is such
as weird dastardly awful media character
take off his cloak and he has like
otherwise it's gonna be very easy or at
least very satisfying to see cuz he's
the guy who designed the scorpion he's
the guy who knows where wildfire is kept
like he needs to be taken down at some
interesting satisfying way and the fact
that he has his little birds his army of
Newsies that are helping him influence
Westerosi events and be interesting to
see if one of those kids takes off the
masks I'm just going to throw a will
wild guess here we have Danny is going
to be killed by John okay and that'll be
like the big painful thing then I think
that Cersei will be killed by Jaime
somehow still even though we're like
he's gonna support her I don't know
maybe it has to do that and this is all
made up random but yeah it's all
confirmed and then Arya I'm just
throwing out there right now that she's
actually gonna kill the mountain but as
part of the mountain
killing sand or sandor clegane like they
are having Clegane bull and like it
previously went back in season four
the mountain is unbeatable especially
since he's already dead maybe he's done
some real damage or something but maybe
he delivers a death blow basically to
the hound and then Aria comes in and she
takes the mountain down who is someone
that she wanted to kill absolutely yep
and then saying there's like wait that's
your own fish that was my unfinished
business my finished business and then
he dies yeah I mean one of those moments
yeah I could see that happening or Aria
decides to spare someone you know
because she's such a badass killer
because she's like invincible almost it
seems like maybe she drops a sword and
then she's like I've already beaten you
know and she just you know she sails
Westeros like Frodo
I'm super excited to just point out that
this person has sent us a bunch of
questions every week and that's why she
is our winner
our first winner smashing ivory we are
going to reach out to you very soon
and you are going to get flown out from
your hometown as long as it's real cheap
no no I'm kidding but you are going to
join us at our VIP screening and our
live taping of this show I'm super
excited your questions have been really
good every week we haven't featured you
every time but you've been getting entry
points every single time you have and we
we're really looking forward to meeting
you but also you get to bring a friend
which is really exciting because Game of
Thrones is super sad to do alone yeah
hope you'll be with us too so you can be
our friend but also if there's another
one of you that wants to join us and
join the party you can still submit yeah
next week next week we're gonna announce
who the final winner and you know
they'll have a plus-one that they can
bring that's gonna be it could be you
could be used to keep sending us your
questions and we'll pick one of you guys
next week to also join us yeah let's
move on yeah to our kill count so every
episode we keep track of how many people
died and who killed him and who had the
most kills and a lot of people had beef
with us last week for not giving Aria
like thousands of kills and it's like
yeah you kind of could most of those
were shatters so I would say yeah and
that's my cool so I'll say
I'm still stand by her her everyone
counted the most certainly but I'm like
Americans so for our kill count you're
on Greyjoy definitely had one big kill
with with ragle it wouldn't if you kill
another major character that gives you
major points but also probably many more
off-screen humans those ballistas were
shattering ships said we can't I mean I
don't want to give him credit for all of
it right like the eighth ship had one of
those so shouldn't Qyburn get some
credit for designing he's the
Oppenheimer of that weapon so yeah yeah
but also gregor clegane got another huge
kill by beheading miss sunday yeah man I
I was just like hoping for something at
that last second of course it wasn't
gonna happen but like some sort of you
know swing move which were miss on day
like wraps around Cersei and takes her
down with no one's gonna stop her her
life's over anyway she just grabbed her
and jumped you know yeah get that win
but yeah but sad she died but that's
that's it actually so our counting
person who's been helping us was like
well you know what there wasn't much
kills to count but there were a lot of
other poking to count so he kept a sex
count this week and I feel like we
should have like music for this like six
counts yeah but who boned
well of course Jaime and Brienne hooked
up Brienne punched a vCard good for her
but if you caught this background
Podrick uh was we knew he's hooking up
with one girl she smiled at him but then
the girl with the Hound scared away ran
over to him and he whispered something
and she got this big smile this guy's
walking away with both ladies he's potty
sex God we still don't know for sure
what he did with those uh with those
ladies down in King's Landing to keep
them so happy afterward it seemed like
maybe he might have done a song he did
sip during the drinking game when the
idea of virginity came up I may be just
sipping awkwardly some beaver thinkin
maybe he's just gonna go sing to these
ladies and that's you know that's it
yeah and let's say
who else is left their brand and the
tree here so there was a lot of hooking
up going on the way that way any scenes
yeah yeah torment hooked up with one of
those those girls yeah maybe you should
be yeah so everyone's everyone's getting
some okay but now let's it's time to
move on to our ranking yeah so this is a
part of the show where you guys decide
who you thought won the episode we sent
out our Twitter poll last night you guys
voted in third place seven point eight
percent of who won the episode you're on
Greyjoy it's fair I just can't like but
I got abstain sometimes you don't have
to vote just because somebody is the you
know best candidate I wish people
wouldn't both if you think like he had a
big win it seemed that we were satisfied
or happy about but yeah there's a big
power moment for him by taking down a
dragon you get some votes on that one in
second place with 11.2% Sansa Stark yeah
definitely is the gossip queen power
moves yeah is what she's doing and
that's why Littlefinger previously I had
I think there was an episode where he
won the power ranking last season until
he very much lost it right but yeah
those moves I mean she just by spreading
that secret it shattered everything yeah
by dropping on some drama with the crew
right before they go on their road trip
and because she was invited on the road
trip that's that's definitely a Power
Move yeah and then first place 64.7% of
the vote so everybody was feeling it
this week and I guess it's undeniable
Cersei Lannister yeah I mean she she
decimated the the remaining already
decimated force right right well I mean
that's why I deserve some of the votes
there because he was the one who won
that naval victory but her calculation
to to partner up with Iran definitely
paid off big time this episode and her
unwillingness to back down when Tyrion
came up and tried to negotiate with her
it's definitely very powerful moment for
her she didn't need to kill Masson day
that was like she had a captive that she
could have used to sue for peace server
you know to get them to back down her to
exchange something but she just said no
she I should just even need this so she
killed our move and a lot of people are
probably thinking Oh
there's no way that they're gonna
convince her to just give up the Kapton
why not they could put her over a
Casterly Rock they could set her up real
nice like Olenna Tyrell was just like
growing old happy at Highgarden so there
there are negotiations that could have
happened that was very much saying we
you know we will not negotiate there is
no peace yeah as an option and and
definitely a powerful move to bring in
the townspeople of King's Landing inside
the walls of the the red keep yeah
because that just it's something that
I'll point out in the breakdown it's a
big dictator move and even though it's a
pretty disgusting thing to use people as
human shields it's definitely a powerful
thing also often used in propaganda
where do you know you claiming that your
enemy is really they're just hurting the
the common people sometimes it's even
your disguising soldiers as as just
commoners who are the ones that are you
know being slaughtered by you by your
enemy yeah but also again that's one of
the biggest reasons why we want to say
we were headed toward tomb at Queen's
because this move is very similar to the
Mad King Aerys who was going to burn all
of King's Landing just so that he could
technically in a way not lose but it's
like at least it's all gone then no one
went yeah and so she's setting up that
move to if I don't win no one does well
in speaking of like who's winning and
who's who might be losing let's let's
check in with our guest the throne yes
yes the first time that we actually have
data on this because it takes a couple
days for them to calculate so this is
all based on last week's episode with
the long night yes yes yeah okay I keep
calling a battle Winterfell but based on
that everybody's submissions and for
their death pool is now assessed and we
have some data about our first place
people we have some data about where we
are so first of all I heard there's like
a tie for first place how many people is
that 200 people are tied for first place
Wow well I mean we didn't have a ton of
characters died we had dollar said we
had Lyanna Mormont
we had Jorah Mormont does it say how am
i there they are they've got everything
right so far about that makes sense it's
some people I mean it's like a dine
first is not though crazy
guess but still that uh like characters
that are living or dead to get
everything right is like week one of the
NCAA tournament you're gonna have a lot
of people are still tied for first place
yeah I'm still impressed III don't think
I'm in that room that bracket okay so of
course some people that are that are
tied in first place there's give them
some shout outs circle gets asked where
you're in first place
Charlotte sometimes Sasha stark the
character who is gonna show up and get
some sassy trouble going Charlize Theron
Charlie hit Charlie T is doing well
and one more and Natalie hey great job
cool yeah and then how are we doing and
things can really obviously be swayed by
who ends up on the iron throne is a big
one yeah there's a lot of bonus points
didn't say what place were in though
page 8 of 20 so yeah we're probably tied
for like I don't know so that would be
like 80th place yes yeah yeah and I know
after this episode I think I don't think
I had Miss on day Darian at the end of
the season so that would have been a
problem oh I had her dead yeah so we'll
see whoever wins this thing gets a prize
that I'm gonna pretend it's not yet to
be determined I'm pretend we actually
haven't figured out actually yeah but we
will figure it out very soon what do you
win yeah and before we move on we want
to take another moment to recognize one
of these sponsors that helped us put out
Westeros weekly story worth and this is
very specific because of where we're
headed next week but yeah next week a
lot of you guys have pointed out that
it's Mother's Day and the different
holidays at Game of Thrones episodes
have aired on have actually like pretty
relevant to the story
yeah like Jon resurrected on Easter and
right exactly yeah was it was Father's
Day when
what's-his-name died Tywin Tywin yeah
yeah
so Mother's Day is coming and we're
headed toward you know these two mothers
going into battle next week so we we
purposely got a sponsor that has a great
idea for Mother's Day
yeah story work that's a really cool way
to connect and stay in touch with your
family so with Mother's Day being May
12th next Sunday or this coming Sunday
you probably haven't gotten your mom
anything have you know you probably have
it you always have story worse yes
story worth is here to help you guys who
forgot here's how it works you subscribe
for someone like your mom they get a
weekly email from story worth with a
question about their life they respond
with a story and at the end of the year
after week after week of answering these
questions story with takes all of their
stories puts them in a really nice
keepsake book it's a great way to stay
in touch with your loved ones that might
not live near you and preserve precious
family memories so for me I set this up
for my mom for Mother's Day Nancy I'm
for Nancy and I'm so excited for her to
get this the first question that it
looks like it's gonna ask her is what
was something that you've won and my mom
is like it's been such like a great
matriarch a person who's like helped it
she's raised five kids he's the boss mom
she's the boss boss my dad was in the
Navy so was often oversea so my mom had
to like raise five kids at times like by
herself and so I want to I'm curious to
know like she's super accomplished you
know she's like brilliant but she has
like a master's degree in biology
she almost worked for the CDC and like I
want to know like and I ruined all of it
me and four others before me so I'm
curious to know like what her
accomplishments are and I want her to
brag about her life that's what this
whole this whole book series or this
book is gonna be is all kinds of things
that you're curious to know about your
mom alright yeah I have amazing stories
that I'm already finding out about my
mom and honestly like about my mom and
dad's relationship but at the very
beginning it's like a Romeo and Juliet
story it's amazing so you can share all
those stories in this book but this was
really great about it it's not just
passed down as a story that you just now
know it turns into a book that can be
you know share to your your aunt's your
cousins you can honestly check off a lot
of gifts right yeah
and with all of my family spread out all
over it's nice to have a way that her
stories can be saved and edited on story
worth com
so for $20 off visit story worth comm
slash rock stars when you subscribe you
still have time to give your mom the
most thoughtful Mother's Day gift in the
world just use the URL story worth com
slash rock stars for $20 off a year
subscription alright so speaking of
Mother's Day again we're Network really
pumped about next week is going to be
Mother's Day so let's watch that teaser
for next week and we're gonna try to
give some quick reactions and maybe some
guesses about how it's going to serve
the Mamas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
mmm a ticking clock yeah right like the
time has come but also that tension
building yeah yeah it was very similar
to you know we were talking about how
it's like Dunkirk you know that yeah
exactly as that simmered ticking yeah
but also taking that look up initially
in Dunkirk it's it is also an aerial
attack then you know one person
witnesses and then everyone realizes one
by one that they're about to be attacked
a lot of people are asking about what
you're on is looking at that moment I
think you saw to right that you can see
the glimpse of a dragon in or the
silhouette of one in the Sun right so
Iran seems like shocked to see exactly
so it's it's either that he was doing
what an idiot does and he's staring at
the Sun and then he's like wait a second
the sun's coming at us guys and then he
realized oh no - dragon and then that's
just a shock or when a lot of people are
wondering I think is just so funny but
also so cool they somehow find a way to
pull this off does drogon show up
wearing like all new threads he's got
like battle armor on oh yeah go ahead
and try to fire at me but now I'm
impervious could Gendry have forged some
battle armor for a dragon yeah like
secretly he's been doing a lot of work
it's not crazy
ancient Targaryen did put armor on their
dress so the it's also a theory that
ties a lot with how war elephants were
used and these also had to be armored
elephants it also had armored horses
it totally is the thing that people do
just the image of him like have you ever
put a dog in shoes it's hilarious I
can't wait I just want to see joke I'm
like no I don't like this we keep it on
yeah it could be that and I think that'd
be one of the most badass things but it
also could potentially slightly connect
to this promo image that HBO is using
all season long of the Iron Throne with
the image of drogon kind of overlaid
into it it kind of gives a little
potential foreshadowing of an iron
drogon yeah yeah yeah that would be
awesome to see please let it be a
surprise and not just a dragon that you
made us seem like it would be something
much cooler yeah alright guys that's it
for Westeros weekly this week thanks so
much for watching do not forget to
subscribe
to this podcast and follow our new
podcasts it's all about the MCU it's
called inside Marvel has all of our
vendors and game content coming out
there again it all comes out before it
comes on the YouTube channel in audio
form because it's just easier to do that
for us and tweet your Game of Thrones
questions at us next week or throughout
the week using the hashtag Westeros
weekly you can follow me also on Twitter
at fimo or on Instagram at Phillip
Malina
and you can follow me on Instagram or
Twitter at a gave us we got some really
great videos about Game of Thrones
coming up but also obviously we're gonna
hit up that Spiderman new far from home
trailer that just came out a lot of
great stuff this week so stay tuned we
love you
[Music]